[Music]
to start with what Drew you all
initially to this project and let's
start with youen
you well
I I
remember in 2012 when everything started
I was in
Mexico and and and watching the news at
night and all of a sudden I saw they
were talking about this uh about the
magazine the covering the magazine and
they were saying that this little girl
from a public school in
Matamoros H she was considered in the US
like the next Steve Jobs and I was
really curious about the whole story but
they they didn't say that much and years
later um uh the the the journalist who
wrote the article contacted us at the
office to offer us the the rights to
make a movie about this and I
immediately told uh uh Ben my business
partner and I remember the story so and
then I learned that there was there was
a teacher behind Paloma and immediately
uh it was it was the perfect uh story
for the for for us for the company and
when did you know that Chris was the
right director to bring on and also
would love to hear your personal
connection to it Chris uh yeah uh Chris
and I went to film school together and
graduated in 2004 I think um and we made
a movie together that Chris wrote while
he was in film school called pin o
westro s mang which came out of sang
mangri Thank You IFC for making that
confusion um but uh and ohen who I just
met um around that time uh was on
Broadway when we were shooting the movie
and uh Chris really wanted uh a a
Mexican actor in the kitchen because all
the kitchens in New York at the time
were Mexican were Mexican and there were
no Mexican actors in New York CU all the
Mexican actors went to LA and he was on
Broadway so I called him one day and
said I know we just met uh but would you
ever want to be in this little drama
with no money you're going to have to
change out of a van and uh and it's
going to be horrible and he said yes cuz
he wanted to do drama and he hadn't done
it so that's how how Chris and I started
our journey together uh and then when we
read the article it you know uh I just
knew with Chris his um his sort of
Relentless pursuit of an authentic story
tell authentic storytelling was what
this needed like and rawness that well
he delivered it I think by by the way he
won the sun film festival with sangra
mangri in 2007 and then he came back
with the radical and he won again the
fund Film Festival this
year thank
you so with all that with all that
preface and buildup so when when I won
Sundance we were the last movie of the
night the experience was really kind of
terrible the whole week we were the
cheapest movie there by far we were in
Spanish we were dark I believe someone
said it was like whoever made this movie
hates Humanity it's like a kick to the
teeth um and then at the very end of the
entire night the last award they get is
the grand Jerry prize for us dramatic
and um and I'll Never Forget Sarah poly
uh calling calling the award and uh and
and and I I told this story actually to
lur hry s in a car um so apparently I
gave the longest speech in the history
of Sundance except true um and and
actually I don't remember any of it
because what was going through my head
over and over again was this this uh
just broken record I am a fraud and I
fooled them all and they're stupid and
I'm a
fraud and and I probably could have
survived it until Ben showed me the
video of
myself uh doing the speech and and it
was really the beginning of a of a
journey where I just completely lost my
track and and went like just um kind of
lost even my love for film making and so
I decided to take my my wife who's an
adventurous spirit and my 10-month-old
son and we moved to Guatemala um where I
lived I ended up living for eight years
and through just kind of starting over
and finding the love um came to love
working again and in the midst of that
Ben sent me this article which now I had
a four-year-old or a 5-year-old who was
just getting into school I was trying to
get him in the school system there is
very much like this one it had had no
kind of relationship to education it was
more like you know hurting cats and um
you know I had also I had also become a
father um um but the story of a teacher
and I don't I don't know how much you
got from the actual backstory of Sergio
but of a guy who basically had a nervous
breakdown what the only thing he wanted
to do he was not succeeding he just
desperately tries this new thing I
connected to that personally I think the
the the fatherhood and the and the
school thing was very personally and
then oh yeah we had this thing called
the pandemic and you know
School online for
kindergarten which is what I was
witnessing and here I am like I I I I
got so much it was so much there was so
much suffering but I had so much respect
for teachers how do they do this
Wizardry um all that was sort of in the
moment of of writing of when Ben sent it
to me and then writing it and I I was
just I I couldn't not do it I just
couldn't not do it and I'm glad you said
authenticity Ben because that's what
struck me the first time I saw and the
second time I saw the film um I have
family that's from that region of Mexico
and it just it feels lived in I feel
like I'm walking those streets with them
um and something that I feel like really
stands out from other teacher narratives
is how you face head-on the difficulties
of their lives but you still end on a
hopeful note how did you strike that
balance that was to to that's to to you
well I think you know I mean first of
all um Dead Poet Society probably
changed my
life um I I we're just talking about
this outside that that that event that
was on the news a few years back of like
all these kids and red Trump hats
circling around an indigenous person at
the at the mall and shotting them down
that was my high school those kids and
to see that you know this idea that
movie that you can you cannot follow the
crowd you can do your own thing probably
made me a
filmmaker um so you know you know I
think it just start there um I'll pass
on to Ben for a minute because I'm
getting angry about those guys right now
no look you know when we started talking
about it what was I think exciting for
all of us is that it's a genre that
feels like it's been done a lot but it
really hasn't it's probably been I don't
know there's probably 10 movies out
there maybe you throw the coach movies
in there too but um the the idea of
taking it and setting it in a place
we've never seen a story like this
before obviously a true story and and
through the vision of Chris who who
really grinds things down and makes them
raw and
real it it felt like there was a a way
to sort of Honor that genre that we love
so much but also subvert it in small
ways um
but the ending in fact we talked about
the ending from the beginning I think I
was always the one that was sort of like
I think it ends on the on the exam
because um it felt like getting those
kids there after a tragic event was
going to be kind of the most important
piece and then everything else that you
can kind of let it roll at the end but
we talked a lot about as he was Chris
Chris when he writes like you become his
Muse whether you like it or not and we
have hundreds of pages of Internet of
emails to prove it but um we were trying
to figure out how you can sort of thread
that needle and make it feel hopeful
without making it feel false right um
and and and I have to just just jump in
though I think one thing that's really
critical there it's it it is uplifting
but it's also extremely heartbreaking
yeah I think and and it's and it's this
idea and I don't think these kind of
movies have done that before they end on
the uplifting note and to me I think it
was really important you know a teacher
can can affect so much change but at the
end of the day I mean like who's the
antagonist in this movie it's like their
circumstances it's Society it's there
there there are still bigger deeper
problems like yeah education can help us
chip away at them education is probably
the most profound fundamental place we
can start but the reality of of our
society and and it's a mistake to think
of this as something that's happening
only in Mexico it's we have the same
issues here you know and and it's pretty
common around the world but but there
are problems that are bigger and deeper
um and and I and and it just felt to to
both of us like to to to really hit the
right note here we need to leave it with
that complication um on some ofel we
enjoy the the we enjoy the joy that is
learning and possibility but but it
would be I think not not genuine and not
not accurate to just sort of say and
it's all G to be fine yeah and and and
by the way one thing Chris did so well
in his first movie that that always
stuck with me is it's a very open-ended
uh ending on sang mang and um there's
something very powerful about it forcing
you into a dialogue as you leave the
theater you you're still in dialogue
with the movie and so there was a lot of
conversation around and I I love how he
ends the movie because it does leave you
with can that kid ever get there is
there there's always going to be a kid
left outside of the system and um and I
think the other thing that oh henu and I
talked a lot about when we read the
article was like how does this guy get
up every day and do this how does he do
that and that I think was your big expl
ation as a as an actor like how do you
do that when you know that you're going
to roll that rock up a hill and it's
going to come right back down again what
gets you going in the
morning well sir here was telling me let
me tell you the story really quick he he
he was telling me that he wasn't sure of
what he was
doing and he was doubting all the time
he thought he was probably derailing and
and he was like what am I doing with the
kids probably they're going to lose the
year I'm going to ruin their lives
I'm going to get fired but it was more
his his hunger for change he wanted to
move from there he doesn't want to be in
in you know in the same spot he wanted
to make a change and so it it was more
that than the fear of of failing so U he
kept going and and he finally achieved
this amazing goal but he was always
doubting I think one of the most
subversive things in my opinion that
subverts this movie that Chris was so
insistent on was that feeling of just
never knowing what the hell he's doing
and going into it without just blindly
and Chris was constantly pushing that
feeling you know in working with oeno
and and and then just being plainly
honest about it with the students um to
to show his vulnerability to be instead
of the authority who had all the answers
and sort of looked down at them and told
them do this he's like I don't know what
do you think
um and I felt like that that was a great
way to to um in a in a way
dis um uh I think it's also really
helpful to disarm the audience um to him
but but I I think you know and and and
this thing I remember Ben and I were
certain we were going to end the movie
before the you know we weren't going to
have the scene where the TV trucks pull
up and and celebrate the results of the
test and then what did I do with the
first draft I put that and's like what
are you doing I thought yeah oh God
you're right you're right yeah yeah uh
but the point of the movie really I
think is how did he do this that was the
that was the dramatic question that you
know I think excited us as filmmakers
and storytellers to try and figure it
out and it turns out it is this kind of
relationship where you do treat the
treat children like they're really
interesting beings that have really
interesting things to say and they can
really do kind of anything and this is
just a a little vignette but we were
lucky enough to have Serio come to the
set and he was there quite a bit like
almost as an
advisor and I was just so struck with
his phone was just blowing up the whole
time and I finally said what's going on
there and he's like oh these are my
students there's students from the last
10 15 years of his life who are in
constant touch with him and it's just
like yeah we got that
right Ando what was it like for you to
have Serio on sat that often oh my God
was really
scary I mean when for any actor when
you're portraying someone who exist that
it's always a challenge when but when
you have to play someone who's still
alive and that you know he's going to
watch the
movie and and when I I remember I was
shooting one day uh probably third
fourth day and somebody from production
told me said he was
here and I was like what the real said H
they were like yeah and was where where
is he he's in the monitor watching oh my
God it was it was really scary and
intimidating but you know on the other
hand I was able to previously of course
to talk to him and and ask him a lot of
questions about his relationship with
the kids ER we wanted to be as accurate
as possible um so everything that you
see in the movie it's real it was kind
of let's say supervised by him and and
Paloma so we wanted to be really
truthful to the
story and it's so beautifully done and
your performance is just outstanding I
as soon as you go in with the kids and
you're there and you're telling them all
to get on the boats it's just like this
ray of light um that that's funny cuz
that's exactly how I would describe him
as a
person that definitely came through
thank thank you Chris thank you very
much now I was well I I was really
scared because you know I'm usually a
comedian I I I'm always making people
laugh and I was so scared about this
role because this is my first dramatic
role starring in a movie so I I was
panicked you know that I was during the
rehearsals I didn't know what I was like
two days before shooting I was like
having cold feet I was like
I think I'm doing the wrong thing I
should just be producing but uh but I I
mean I at the end I just trusted Chris
and he was writing so many things but I
I remember I was panicked my my one of
my favorite things working with oeno is
that he likes to work from the hair down
you know yeah so he'll start with like a
crazy hair do and work his way down so
when we started he was like trying to
build this character with all these you
know CU he likes to hide underneath
these things and transform himself into
something else and Chris kept sending
him back up to wardrobe Andra until
finally he came down he just his hair
was a little messy he's wearing just
basically what he's wearing in the movie
and he looks Over Me Goes hermano I feel
so naked and I just looked and I went
great because this is I I having been
friends with ohoney for 20 years my
dream because I've always the day I met
him I said you can do anything you can
do drama you can do anything and it took
us a while we we wanted to be careful
sort of when he would come out and do a
drama obviously because audience you
want to make sure they're going to show
up for it but um I was just excited to
see him strip down to show the world
what I always saw he could do and I
think he delivered did you guys and it's
yeah thank you very
much and it's it's really hard to have
that conversation when you're having it
with your
boss uh and telling him to get
naked um
um and uh you know I think it's a
testament to too's courage and you
know ieno said something I'm G to share
this I hope you don't mind but but he
said to me you know and it was the hair
it was absolutely the hair was the thing
that broke the the dam um but he was
like people people know me they're used
to me they've seen me and this is true
in Mexico he's been in their living
rooms for their entire lives their
parents' lives he he's just he's I mean
if you don't know who he is in Mexico
he's the biggest thing ever literally
you cannot describe it and and you know
everybody knows me I've got to do
something different so that you know and
and I sort of felt like no they don't
that's a you're actually
hiding and and I I don't want you to
hide and I don't um and the way you have
to sort of get in there with somebody
likeo who's so he's such a perfectionist
he's so driven to get it right was you
know but remember Sergio how he didn't
know what he was doing he was doing
something for the first time also and he
was probably terrified and like he had a
nervous breakdown what if it doesn't go
right like he's on a high rope what if
he falls off like that's exactly how
we're gonna make you
feel and we're gonna film it uh but but
but the truth is I think we're just
seeing the the result of actually
getting ueno and I think we're like
scratching the surface of something and
it's going to keep going and I'm I'm
just going to sit back and be a huge fan
watch
it I'd love to take a moment to talk
about the performances of the kids in
this film they're just so incredible and
so natural and I read that it was their
first films yeah um what was your
approach to
that um well I had I had first of all it
was it was exhaustive tireless casting
um to just find sort of the right
elements
I think the one where where everyone was
the most nervous was Nico who we
couldn't find Nico at all in Mexico City
we looked at I don't know on many many
hundreds of kids and um finally we
decided to go send Scouts up to the
Border we thought maybe we needed this
like slight Edge and so we sent uh
people to um tamas the state that the
story takes place in and and actually um
one of the scouts or one of the people
that was you know taping the
announcement for the try for the
auditions open auditions on on Telephone
polls went home to his son and said hey
maybe you got to try out for this and
that's
ni um and he had he had this you know
and I think but everybody was a little
nervous about him because as as he told
us on the first day he like I'm very
pretty uh and we wanted this kind of
Edge and that was that was one one way
to go and he he did have a little kind
OFA a little anger but he also had this
incredible insecurity vulnerability that
I thought just did something special for
him in that character and it would be a
slightly different way to to tell the
story of that kid who's kind of on the
edge and why he's on the edge and so I
was I I fought for him pretty hard I
didn't have to fight hard with these
guys or anything it was you know the
whole process of the director's dream it
was just like that you show you that's
what you want okay that's what we're
doing um but but I had this other secret
weapon which was this
man uh who uh you know I I had an idea
like that first scene where they meet
him only three kids were allowed to
know uh who was in the movie with with
them because if the other kids knew we
would have ground to a complete halt
because the production would have been
mobbed um and and so we we told the
three kids and we shot the first
scene literally on the first scene where
they come meet him it was when they
found out they were working with aino
and I shot their side first just to see
if I could get anything I think they
were so freaked out we didn't get
anything uh but um but oeno I'll let you
talk about it but um he just has this
incredible way with kids and and he's
worked with kids before and I'll let you
talk about it but it was um it was you
know just an indispensable part of what
we got well well I I was not a kid
person back uh in 2007 he has four
children by the
way well that's it's another kind of
thing but uh it
was 2007 and I I I was about to started
shooting a movie called under the same
Moon beautiful movie yeah I know and and
um and after that I Was preparing for
instruction not
included and I I I had to work with kids
and I was not a kid person honestly and
I I told Patricia RI and the director I
was like how does it I mean how how how
does it work because how am I going to
work with this kid and she was like well
you need to bond with him and we like I
mean um while we're shooting she was
like no no no offc screen taking I for
an ice cream or something it was like
me I me I don't what are we going to
talk about I mean I'm I'm I don't know
how to do this anyway she was like you
have to be with him 24/7 and it's true
that's the secret that that's what I did
in r
it's a 24/7 job you have to be friends
with the kids all the time so I remember
uh since I arrived at 6:00 a.m. to the
makeup trailer you know I had to be
making jokes and telling stories and and
playing with them sometimes I wanted to
keep memorizing my lines and they were
like it's like having 30 kids at the
same time I was trying to concentrate
and they were like hey look at this look
at this painting around running around I
have hey
wo but that was the only way and and it
worked honestly it worked I remember
that uh probably
um 10 days later after we started one of
the kids was like hey can I ask you a
question I was like yes how can I
impress a girl and that was the moment
when I said I'm doing I'm really bonding
with them because they they were like
really trusting me so and it was worth
it honestly we became a family I'm about
to post in the next days the last day of
shooting where we couldn't keep shooting
because they were crying so bad it was
actually it was the the the scene that
the last scene when the exam when I
gather with them and I tell them then
that I cry I was crying because that was
our last day together oh that that was
the the final scene and it was everybody
was crying when the camera was on the
other side and he turned around and be
like no no no no no no now hold it hold
it yeah that was real and that's because
we really became a family and and we we
couldn't stop crying that day so we got
really emotional and you know also you
know these kids were not actors um some
of them wanted to be so that's why they
answered casting calls but they hadn't
worked before many of them were just
from the the town the little village we
were in and just like answered you know
they were making hundred bucks a day or
whatever to contribute to their family
and imagine like you like they literally
would they would go home every day and
say Mom Dad I was just working with the
best and they' like yeah right it took
about three weeks until like it was all
the kids in the town were like yeah and
finally some parents started like and
then and then we did actually get mobed
and almost grind to a halt um but but I
think the other thing was was just and
and if if if it if the conversation
comes back this I'll talk about it more
but was the way in which and I I kept
being struck with it over and over the
way in which the movie was really the
the the example the proof almost of the
story that we were telling which was
that if if you take these kids I I talk
to them all absolutely like adults I
don't have I don't have I don't do kid
talk and and they had oeno to look up to
as this incredible figure mentor kind of
shining example and then they had each
other as kind of peer pressure to to to
cheer each other on and almost try hard
together um and and on some level you
know um the movie really was to me proof
of the story that we were telling that
you know this genius is everywhere it
just needs to be um um seen and and
empowered um so you know that would be
my other answer to to that question yeah
thank you I believe believe that we are
at time but I just wanted to say a
personal thank you because I as I
mentioned before I have family and demoz
and one of the things that my cousin
told me is nobody cares about us nobody
cares about what happens to us so I have
to thank you for making this well it's
funny just I just just want to add on to
that we we met with Serio today actually
we did a we met um with a a recreo it's
called like a a Convention of teachers
in the state of halisco was online there
were 6,000 people people in the room and
there were 20 to 70,000 watching it live
streaming online and we went on this
morning Meo and the real Paloma Serio
was at school teaching he couldn't
join uh but we met him a week or so ago
and starting this idea of how do we get
something going in Mexico with the
education system we're here we're here
right now right now all of us are here
right now because of this dream this
idea this guy had to start in his own
neighborhood and like the audacity to
change the world and I'm like dude
you're doing it so how do we keep the
dream going if you could if you could
have whatever you want what what would
your dream be and I think he's gonna say
oh I want to replicate the model and you
know my idea is like we'll do learning
Labs after school this whole thing and
he says knock the wind out of me he said
I would just like teachers to be valued
more and yeah oh this whole movie was
like that but you know I'd like to think
that okay we'll do that but let's start
with this you know hopefully this
triggers a conversation whether it's
here or it's in Mexico or everywhere
else in the world but um I know we feel
mandated thank you so much thank you for
sharing this fil thanks
[Music]
everybody